Hillary Clinton hilariously reads Donald  Trump quotes oh I can't read no is it  bad the 68 year old presidential hopeful  was a guest on jimmy kimmel live on  monday and the host challenged her to a  game of reciting Donald Trump quotes the  catch she wasn't allowed to laugh I  think apologizing is a great thing but  you have to be wrong I will absolutely  apologize sometime in the hopefully  distant future if I'm ever wrong clearly  Hillary succeeded congratulations if I  were running the view I'd fire Rosie  O'Donnell I mean I'd look at her right  in that fat ugly face of hers I'd say  rosy you're fired all right that's not  funny the former Secretary of State  couldn't even bring herself to read the  last quote so Jimmy did it for her I've  said if Ivanka weren't my daughter  perhaps I'd be dating her